[Musique]
papa on s'ennuie tellement fermé ici
dehors c'est le cas il fait très froid
et ça fourmille de brigands j'ai envie
de sortir je veux aller à kastoria c'est
beaucoup trop loin
oscar les chats ne sont pas des oiseaux
ils ne peuvent pas vraiment folle et
regarde j'ai fabriqué une fusée est
partie dans une incroyable aventure avec
rot star
à découvrir le monde des chats
[Musique]
nous devons les sauver
je ne le vois plus
manche at-on d'intérieur interne aussi
pourquoi tu cherches 4 sinovia je n'ai
pas envie de devenir aussi paresseux
dépêchons-nous
diverses et 28 blessés
cet endroit catch tout cas est-ce que
cela il existe c'est un monde légendaire
qui n'existe que dans les coeurs mais
c'est dangereux ça brouille tout besson
[ __ ] laveur qui dope les autres
s'amusent
je n'ai pas peur
il reste quand même très dangereux
je vais lui
ce vaste monde est à toi découvre le
soin audacieux oscars et les chars
le 12 décembre au cinéma là ouais
[Musique]